there has been another crash involving
children at a school bus stop this time
it happened in Tampa Florida five
children and two adults were taken to a
hospital yesterday after a car struck
them near a bus stop now this is the
latest of at least five crashes at
school bus stops this week alone five
children have been killed Tony Tecopa
was outside a school in New York with
what's being done to try to stop these
crashes from happening Tony good morning
good morning
Gayle right about now all over the
country some 500 thousand school buses
like this one are picking up 25 million
kids and getting them to school
hopefully on time it's one of the
largest u.s. transit systems and experts
tell us it is by far the safest way to
get to and from school at least once
those buses are on the road the string
of accidents this week though highlights
the dangers of getting on and off the
bus it's an ever-present danger passing
drivers putting children at risk at
school bus stops see that it was coming
at a fast rate of speed said Laura
Chavez she and her six-year-old son were
one of seven people rushed to a hospital
on Thursday after being hit by a car at
a school bus stop in Tampa
[Music]
about an hour earlier a seven-year-old
boy died after being hit by a car while
waiting for a school bus in Pennsylvania
and in Indiana on Tuesday a pickup truck
hit and killed nine year-old Olivia
Stahl and her six-year-old twin brothers
as they crossed the road to get to their
bus police charged the pickup trucks 24
year old driver with three counts of
reckless homicide she says she didn't
realize a school bus headed in the
opposite direction was stopped in front
of her each year we see about 120
fatalities Deborah Hersman is president
and CEO of the National Safety Council
and former chairman of the National
Transportation Safety Board the number
one takeaway is really for the drivers
of cars around school buses to be alert
and attentive and look out for the
safety of children several states and
cities have taken action to educate
enforce and strengthen the laws
surrounding school buses police in
Westland Michigan conducted this sting
operation in 2016 stopping several
drivers who blew past a stopped school
bus and posting this video to Facebook
as a warning lawmakers in Mississippi
went a step further after five year old
Nathan ki was killed in 2009 the state
passed
Nathan's law in 2011 which increased
fines for illegally passing stopped
school buses and increased sentencing
for offenders when someone was injured
as a result the charges could be
upgraded against a 22 year old driver
charged with aggravated assault after he
struck and killed nine year old Dale and
Thomas while he was boarding a school
bus on Wednesday we've got to be extra
vigilant when we're in school zones when
we're around school buses because
children don't always have the judgment
to recognize the hazards they're
counting on adults to look out for their
safety and speaking of looking out for
safety school bus stop locations are
often the responsibility of local
authorities or the school districts
themselves were also reminded that as
daylight saving ends this weekend it's
responsible it's the responsibility of
all of us to take extra precautions as
many kids are gonna be going to school
in the dark be honor all of our
responsibilities those videos are so
hard to watch Tony thank you